you're a sports star with a
$26,000 watch what makes this watch
yours what makes it so special this
watch was made from the same letter that
was my spikes I ran in in ' 08 when I
broke the world record for the first
time it has my signature on the back
also my sign pose and it's has a
Jamaican colors inside so for me they
when they told me all this I was excited
just to have a watch hubo isn't the only
brand you work with you've got Samsung
you've got virgin you are the face of
Puma why these brands for me uh I think
different brands are bringing different
perspective of different people so Puma
appeals to a different set of people oo
everybody appeals to a different set of
people I think so it helps to build my
brand around the world so when I retire
I can do different different things is
it time for Puma to step it up when we
see Kevin Durant get paid over 300
million bucks for his shoes I'm guessing
your shoes are more important it's
stressing sometime when you see
different people making different money
but for me I try not to uh worry about
that um sometimes I said it's it's
frustrating to know that just different
sports it's such a big gap sometimes but
I just live with what I have to do and
just do what I have to do you can't
really too stress about it because I
personally can't do anything about it
should you get more from the sport the
Olympic Committee has made so much off
of you over your career did they owe you
more for me I don't I don't try I don't
try to argue about that I think a lot of
athletes says they need to pay but I I
really don't try to stress about it I
try to focus and do what I have to do uh
it wasn't there when I came in so I
can't fight about it now I think uh
maybe in the future the future atlet may
have a good point but I've been in the
sports for a while so I really can't
complain about it now because I'm really
stepped up the game but for me I enjoy
promoting the sport and making it better
so more sponsors and more people so I
can make it better for the future if you
and your personality and your stardom
and your dancing didn't make your way
into track and field would it be this
big would we care about it or would it
have run off in the distance I know I'm
responsible for a lot of people who want
to see track and field but you never
know would have come along or what would
have happened so for me I'm happy that I
God gave me a tal and I came out here
and I did it all right start over if you
weren't a runner what do you wish you
would do with your life uh I would
definitely be in sports you love music
though would you like to be a DJ that
would be cool I think that's the
ultimate job ultimate job is a DJ yeah
get to listen to music every night get
to just be among great people and just
Rave all the time I don't think you can
ask anything else it's just mad fun in
20 years what do you want to do just
dancing in Jamaica I just for me um I
just want to relax I don't want to work
too much too much stress I think uh a
guy who works out 6 hours a day doesn't
want to work too much I'm I'm I'm
surprisingly I'm very lazy
I'm just you're lazy yeah I'm just a
hard worker because that's what my dad
taught me to work hard for what I want